le monde de la culture n'a jamais été
aussi près du gouffre festival annulés
ou reportés théâtres salles de cinéma
des concerts fermé plus aucun tournage
de films en france la vie culturelle
s'est figée elle qui pèse 44,5 milliards
d'euros et fait vivre un million trois
cent mille personnes
c'est trois fois plus que l'industrie
automobile stéphane ricordel est aux
côtés de sa compagne laurence de mark
allen co directeur du théâtre monfort et
du festival paris quartier d'été
jamais ils n'oublieront ce 12 mars où
tout s'est soudain arrêté voilà la fin
des plaines le spectacle est en train de
jouer on s est super tard on a bu du
champagne c'était notre dernière soirée
comment parler grippette de petit truc
dont on savait pas les masses pas les
masques en tout cas tout allait bien
encore on est tous heureux là on est
tous heureux on et 450 dans la salle
et puis pour le lendemain on est hyper
inquiet on va tous chercher du real y en
a pas des masses qui n'a pas aidé c'est
hyper grave mais on est enfermé le
problème c'est précisément le flou
artistique qui entoure les mesures
concrètes qu'attend le secteur culturel
qui pourra ouvrir comment quelles aides
d'état alors qu'on estime d'ores et déjà
à 590 millions d'euros la perte de
chiffre d'affaires pour le seul secteur
du spectacle vivant privé
des chiffres qui donnent le tournis
beaucoup craignent avoir tiré le rideau
rouge pour de bon on a aussi un
directeur d'un festival donc on avait la
dynamique encore du festival et on ya
cru jusqu'au dernier moment sont pour
entrer dans le déni de cette de cette
pandémie mais en se disant on va peut
être essayer d'inventer de réinventer
c'est donc on a travaillé son plein
d'hypothèses jusqu'au moment où
effectivement le flou artistique du
ministère de la culture avec des petits
festivals des petits dieux des petites
chaises des petits mots on s'est dit bon
c'est n'importe quoi il n'y a pas de
chien pas vraiment de lignes on comprend
rien donc on a été obligé de fait
d'annuler
aussi ce festival au moins 2 au mois de
juillet donc en fait on n'a pas de
visibilité aussi bien même pour la
rentrée même inquiétude dans le monde de
la musique
le secteur qui était déjà mal en point
voient mal comment il pourrait se
relever sans la mise en place d'un
véritable plan marshall
cette simple flic confiné réalisées aux
quatre coins de la france et visionner
trois millions 600 mille fois sur
youtube sonne comme un appel politique
mais sans trop d'espoir d'être entendue
au sommet d'état pour les ministres de
la culture qui sortent des grandes
écoles
là c'est uniquement l'opéra les baleines
les pièces afin que chiante
voilà c'est la culture coupure populaire
pour eux ça n'existe pas s'il faut tenir
encore un mois
c'est peut-être possible s'il faut tenir
un an c'est sûr que c'est l'hécatombe
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
de grands noms de la culture ont signé
une tribune publiée le 30 avril dernier
dans le journal le monde un appel à
prolonger d'un an les droits des
intermittents du spectacle pour
l'instant aucune réponse
un silence assourdissant que l'on
regarde d'un oeil et au nez depuis
l'allemagne
richard colombelles est un peintre
français installé à berlin
l'état a dès le mois de mars débloqué
une aide d'urgence de 50 milliards
d'euros pour les indépendants du monde
de la culture nous a en allemagne ça a
été extrêmement facile l'aide a été
extrêmement efficace et rapide
ça a remplacé le salaire de toutes les
personnes qui ont des charges à payer
charge d'ateliers charge de de logement
de nourriture
les premiers les nécessités première
dans un tweet posté samedi dernier
emmanuel macron a fait savoir qu'il
dévoilerait ses mesures pour le secteur
culturel ce mercredi 6 mai une
allocution pour le moins attendu